so the train departs in 80 minutes takes
about five to ten minutes for the uber
arrive about 10 to 15 minutes to get to
the station so it's already half hour I
should get there half hour early I need
10 minutes to pack I'm going to Chicago
I booked an overnight train ride so what
am i doing let's play one more playing
Kenny G 1487 okay let's take down Kenny
G and maybe I'll play Omid in one last
game later in the future at some points
whoa
Petrov okay let's see what he's doing
let's play a Akash room gambit it's a
fun opening against lower rated players
I'm in Central Time North America 3:12
a.m. I usually don't stream at this time
when I was in Asia
I was streaming at weird times like this
but it was normal where I was so the
idea was d4 is that if take says this
and then there's this and then I win the
night with that maybe Bishop g5 first I
want to play Bishop Bishop c4 the lay
Barrett got some more difficult it
becomes so dry Rose okay bishops are
Lively
if I can take on a six and play Queen h5
probably not let's play Bishop H for
maintaining the pin weight d4 is not the
engine move do not know that I've never
studied this seriously maybe I glanced
at once to just check the refutation for
black but you had nothing so serious
well this is looking very nice I'll kick
away the night and I'll get Queen h5 and
life will be good yes black does have
Queen e7 the Queen e7 might be coming
good then I just Castle yeah if takes
takes ticks or q1 oh there's money for
but then an f3 maybe Bishop d5 or queen
h5 yeah let's play queen h5 and then
I'll play Knight c3 next and now the
king still in the center I want to play
rook t1 and crash through
both does gambit that's where you sack
your queen and make a clip of yourself
right yeah the whole idea with e5 is
chase away the Knights got the Queen
here now there's ideas of 95 inclined to
just play rook I correct you on like
open the file my rook has a smile
there's some fun line like takes and
then rook e1 later I'll play this move
when you really like to back rank mates
I would also like to win this e7 pawn
ideas of e6 oe6 looks so funny 6 Queen
takes tix King c8 takes takes I mean I
can win the Queen back
what does that means here here here here
here here here here here
ah the night controls D it it's closed
it's so close v6 when my queen takes on
c7 king CA takes takes Knight b6 King c7
there there so e6 ticks ticks you see it
Knight b6 immediately take sticks just
looking for a quiet move maybe Rucker
key one I mean I don't have to sack my
queen but I want to sack my queen I want
to do a boat s gambits and show her how
to actually do it it's a six and then
they take c7
whoa Alexandria boat has in the chat
gifting five Suggs now I have to do a
boat as gambit but I don't know if it
works
my opponent takes a queen immediately
calls my bluff am i doing I wanna take a
pawn or do I take a bishop let's take
the pawn first yeah this this is all for
soon because then I'll take the bishop
next
thanks for the gifted sons but we have
to focus I could win the Queen back but
I don't want to lose my precious Bishop
I play this move link Bishop d3 so
counterintuitive
that's so slick like beautiful a5 coming
because I have three minor pieces and
two rooks
and two beautiful open files and five
gifted subs salty to taro hungers plenum
Magikarp prevel revelation and palak and
I have her key one check this is gotta
be working or key one King Effie I'll
take a bishop wait a minute
it's so close just take the bishop right
away I'm missing my queen
that's okay Bishop's to keep me company
mmm and the checks are gonna keep coming
King g7 maybe G for delayed Rob how do I
get to the king now my time is running
where's my my wind you want to check
with the dark squared bishop well let's
play this move knife f5 incoming my
opponent says time to flag wait I'm not
gonna flag gonna try my best
King Japanese tutor in the chat and
Alexandre boat as saying please win
we'll try really trying wait where's my
mates King g6 is like only Oh King f6
also on the move trying to find the
means
okay b4 cuz I don't know what else to do
kick away this night
yeah the Knights kind of annoying
just get rid of it I mean nine seconds
left
what there's no increment I got so long
time well interesting move I was good I
thought follows in a fork let's take
here now my puns just trying to like
spite flag me two seconds left let's do
it
I would show my muscle but I don't even
lift bro okay one second left I gamma to
the Queen
gifting morsels from botas there's more
subs thanks so much motifs I wanted to
mate in some beautiful fashion and then
I had to like grind out the end game
like this position it was so close just
a whole party like around the King oh so
so close so now the King found like
shelter in the hurricane it's like the
eye of the hurricane is on f6 not there
analysis for it was there any point
where I miss forced me and I really
thought I had something around here but
maybe I don't sawfish sock fish knows
best
yeah coolest my opponent for surviving
it's getting out of checks I was just
lost for more and now this was actually
impressive I was expecting this and then
I would fork but this is a very good
move and then yeah if my opponent was
maybe not as generate or not so generous
giving back the Queen the countering
potest gambits not a good time for that
Alexandra vote has good nights yeah it's
it's even late in California it's after
1:00 a.m. get some sleep